When it debuts on May 3rd, 2019, the fourth
Avengers movie will be tasked with accomplishing
an unprecedented feat in cinematic storytelling,
tying up one of the most sprawling sagas in
movie history.
But all signs point to one certainty it will
pull it off in style.
Tony's last stand
Considering the end credits scene of Infinity
War, a lot of speculation over the pending
defeat of the Mad Titan Thanos has centered
on the spacefaring Captain Marvel, Carol Danvers.
But comments made by the directing team of
the Russo brothers have heavily implied that
the good Captain won't necessarily be a magic
bullet.
The biggest threat to Thanos may be none other
than Iron Man.
As Infinity War detailed, Thanos and Tony
are on a first-name basis, with both of them
holding deep-seated grudges over the first
Avengers' Battle of New York.
While Captain Marvel's power level will surely
play a part in Thanos' defeat, it makes more
sense that Stark who kicked off the entire
MCU will be forced into a final showdown with
Thanos.
One way or another, it's probably the last
time we'll see Robert Downey Jr. in the role
but does the encounter have to end with his
death?
It's never been more plausible.
Expiring contracts
Not only would a clash between Iron Man and
Thanos in which Stark meets his demise make
narrative sense, it would also make business
sense.
Robert Downey Jr.'s contract with Marvel will
be completed with Avengers 4 and he's not
the only one whose time is up.
While everyone who was snapped away in Infinity
War is probably coming back, the fates of
the original team members are much more up
in the air.
We know that Avengers 4 will also complete
the contracts of Chris Evans, Chris Hemsworth,
and Jeremy Renner.
The status of Mark Ruffalo's deal is unknown,
and though Scarlett Johansson is on board
for a Black Widow solo feature, there's no
guarantee that that film will take place in
the post-Avengers 4 timeline, meaning she
could be done for as well.
There's a reason the original crew survived
Thanos' big Snappening for the old-school
members of the team, Avengers 4 is one last
ride.
End of the Guardians?
The Guardians of the Galaxy series quickly
became one of the MCU's most cherished series
thanks to its adventurous tone and characters
that are outlandish, yet relatable.
Their crossover with the Avengers in Infinity
War was long-awaited, and even though they
mostly turned to dust by the end of that film,
Dave Bautista has confirmed the team will
appear in Avengers 4.
However, Disney's firing of writer-director
James Gunn and subsequent decision to put
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3 on hold has
thrown the entire future of the team into
question.
And it's even been speculated that Avengers
4 may be reworked during reshoots to phase
out Gunn's version of the team permanently.
For all we know, Avengers 4 will be the last
time we see the Guardians something that used
to seem unthinkable.
Returning favorites
Infinity War saw many of our heroes being
reduced to dust, but the fates of more than
a few popular characters remained up in the
air.
Luckily, many of their actors involved with
the movie seem to have difficulty keeping
their mouths shut, cluing us in to a few significant
characters who survived Thanos' snap.
In an interview with ScreenRant during the
promotion cycle for Mission: Impossible Fallout,
Angela Bassett let slip that not only did
her character Ramonda survive, so did her
genius daughter Shuri.
Could she take up the mantle of Black Panther
while her brother is away?
Instagram detectives were also able to all
but confirm that Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie
will also be back after sitting out Infinity
War.
But no sleuthing was required to determine
the fate of Wong, the trusted companion of
Doctor Strange.
The character's actor, Benedict Wong, just
went ahead and posted a photo of himself on
set.
His return will be welcomed, but that skull-peeling
photo has prompted wild speculation from fans
that Wong just might turn out be a Skrull
one of the shape-shifting alien baddies we'll
be introduced to in Captain Marvel.
A cosmic culmination
Infinity War took the saga of the Avengers
to new heights, dramatically raising the stakes
of the conflict with Thanos by having the
Mad Titan actually succeed in his genocidal
mission.
But Avengers 4 will give us something that
the Marvel Cinematic Universe hasn't had to
face until now: a conclusion.
According to Marvel Studios mastermind Kevin
Feige, Avengers 4 the 22nd entry in the MCU
will completely wrap up the ten years' worth
of story that started unfolding with 2008's
Iron Man.
He acknowledged that the individual movies
within the MCU are perpetually in motion,
always leaving viewers on the hook for a sequel
of some sort.
This time, he says, will be refreshingly different.
"We're in the endgame now."
Uncharted territory
Seasoned fans of the MCU know that the studio
has never directly adapted a story from the
comics, but rather used Marvel's decades of
print storylines for inspiration.
The most obvious example of this is Captain
America: Civil War, which took its title from
a famous story arc while sharing only a few
basic plot points with its namesake.
Infinity War is a loose adaptation of the
comics' Infinity Gauntlet story, but Marvel
isn't dipping into its back catalog for Avengers
4 according to directors Joe and Anthony Russo,
it will be a totally original story.
Joe Russo told ComicBook.com,
"I have no interest as a director in telling
a story that's already been told or in seeing
one that's already been told.
If I know all the events of the story as they're
going to happen, then what's the point of
going to the film?"
It's a good point, and one which means that
fans looking to Marvel comics for clues to
the conflict's outcome probably aren't going
to find them.
Comic readers saw Thanos' snap coming from
miles away, but what comes after?
Nobody knows.
Thor speaks
If you're looking for general reassurance
that Avengers 4 will blow your mind just as
hard as Infinity War, look no further than
the words of the Odinson himself,
Chris Hemsworth.
Speaking in an interview with Esquire, the
actor revealed his opinion that Avengers 4
will outdo its predecessor when it comes to
unexpected surprises, saying,
"If you were shocked by [Infinity War], I
think the second one is even more shocking,
for other reasons entirely.
[…] The second one I'm probably even more
excited about."
While we're curious about where the story
will go, assurances like this are almost as
good.
Whatever happens, we're happy to let the wild
speculation continue until the movie's release.
At least, until Mark Ruffalo comes around
and spoils the entire thing for us.
"Wait til ya see this next one easy Mark everybody
dies."
"D-Dude!
Dude..." "... ...not everybody."